this is a production of Cornell
University
well first of all thanks to Anu and
Cathy and and many others for the
invitation the opportunity to come here
it's pretty special visit for me I don't
get back here often enough both of my
degrees are from Cornell so I'm here
visiting very special people and very
special places some of them are in the
audience my sister is one of the staff
members here at Cornell University who
continues to make it a great institution
my wife the maid of honor at our wedding
I think this is the first seminar my
wife has ever seen me gift we got
married at the ad Dixon White House just
down the road so it's an incredibly
romantic time - it's great to be here I
really appreciate it and and I do have
two full-time jobs there at the bottom
of the screen so one is the faculty
director for in fact and the other is
the Kellogg chair and I'm going to tell
you a little bit about Agrico systems
management program first and how we
think about agro-ecosystem
and agro-ecosystem health because that
had a lot to do with the way we shaped
our proposal for what became and is
becoming the initiative for food and
agricultural transformation so this is
me a few years ago when I was here this
is how I got my start as a scout for the
New York IPM programs scouting cabbage
and vegetables across western New York
first for the IPM programs and then as a
private consultant and I would count
bugs and help farmers try to figure out
what to do about these insect pests and
I kept asking you know what isn't there
a better way that we could be going
about this whole thing and if you start
asking those kind of questions pretty
soon you're in a career in research and
that's what happened and so I continued
to work on some of these pests in the
earlier part of my career at Ohio State
so this is one of them this is the
diamondback moth
that's a pupa it's in a broccoli floret
and they're a big problem in broccoli
florets because you can't wash him out
of there
back in the 80s and 90s at least most of
your frozen broccoli was coming from
Central
Mexico the Baguio region and it led to
work with researchers down there where
they were setting out pheromone traps
for these mods and checking them three
times a week every single week from 1987
to 2005
so as entomologist we don't get datasets
like this very often and this led to
some questions about what is going on in
this system that would lead to this kind
of pattern what we showed is three kind
of distinct periods here where the
pattern was changing so one where there
was this kind of regular cyclical
pattern this is using time series
analysis and then a period where the
populations increased and the
fluctuations got really wild and then a
period where they drop down again but
the same pattern of how increases
follows decreases has been maintained
since this this drop-off and this had a
little bit more to do with weather than
anything else well what we were finding
is in looking at what was going on in
this agro-ecosystem that would it best
explain what was going on with this
particular pest it was really a lot
about the amount of broccoli that they
were growing so they went from 8,000
hectares to 40,000 hectares of broccoli
during this period that's a heck of a
lot of broccoli and what it does is
create an enormous carrying capacity for
pests like this but the pest wasn't the
only issue they were starting to have
problems with groundwater with
salinization of the soil with markets
with labor availability the extent that
the processing company down there that
were part of this industry we're already
looking at other parts of the world to
move and get out of this region of
central Mexico so if you keep focusing
on just one problem then usually you
miss what's going on in the system we
have a grand tradition in entomology of
solving one problem and creating three
more in the process and that's great for
job security but after a while it starts
to feel like a game of whack-a-mole you
just keep going from one problem to the
next and fixing that and then
to the next one we like to step back and
take a look at the system instead of
looking at one problem after the next
like I say we have a tradition in
entomology of this we also have a
tradition of this in the land grant
system in general and in our food policy
in the United States so that's kind of
wrapped up in this Byzantine proverb but
you notice who brings you this proverb
but he who has bread has many problems
he who has no bread has only one problem
and that's quite true and we we were
experiencing that right after the Great
Depression so I was just reading the
other night something like 70% of the
young men who joined the Civilian
Conservation Corps were malnourished and
poorly clothed alike when World War two
came along there were a lot of people
that were just not fit to serve in the
military because they were malnourished
now you start having trouble raising an
army and governments get attentive to
that very quickly so this was kind of
the resolve coming out of that period in
our history where there was a decision
across government level we are not going
through those kind of shortages again
we're going to make sure that there's
enough and in the process we've created
a few other issues so this is the bind
that we tend to put farmers in these
days this whole kind of cartoon version
of it but the amount that we all spend
on food that the farmer gets to keep
over the years keeps shrinking because
our food prices are not going way up but
all the costs of what farmers have to
deal with in order to be really
productive keep going up the cost of
inputs the value added beyond the farm
gate so there's a couple ways out of
this squeeze you can get really good at
operating in the middle of it and what
people tend to do there is get
specialized expand get bigger get really
good at using technology so that you can
produce a whole lot because you're not
making much on each unit the other
approach would be to try to recapture
some of the cost of these inputs or some
of the value that's added beyond the
either way it's a very difficult task to
be a farmer these days so in the agro
ecosystems management program this is a
group of faculty at Ohio State
University who were willing to step back
and work with partners outside of the
university on looking for balance and
that's balance between environmental and
the economic and social dimensions of
Agriculture and considering it as a
system it's not just farms it's also
neighboring communities we had a
tradition very early on of working with
people outside the university because we
found if this was a group of academics
talking about big systems kind of stuff
it would get very ethereal very quickly
and so we were interested in making sure
this was grounded in something that
would actually help and one of the
things that we were asked for very early
on was we're talking about this very
complex system it's an environment its
economy its social out of you how do you
get your arms around this can you give
us a way of understanding how we're
doing as an agricultural ecosystem so we
set out to construct an index of agro
ecosystem health and if you're gonna do
that you have to define health first so
we chose this definition that was
proposed quite a while ago by Gordon
Conway he was president of Rockefeller
Foundation at the time he described
agro-ecosystem health in terms of these
four properties and we further fleshed
out what we mean by each of those
properties but if you look at those you
could probably see already that they're
not necessarily things that are moving
in lockstep there's trade-offs within
that list so it's challenging anyway to
talk about agro-ecosystem health in
terms of those four properties we came
up with six key variables that to us
describe the processes that best led to
a definition of those properties over
time and those key variables were kind
of in these six broad character Gauri's
soils and soil health topography
biodiversity and
and the next three are social economic
properties and the idea behind the index
that we came up with is that you have a
pattern on a landscape and you have
things flowing across the landscape some
of its good money going to farmers
beneficial organisms some of it's bad so
pests and diseases flowing between farm
fields some of it just flowing but it's
the pattern of sources and sinks on the
landscape that leads to those flows and
it's the flows that define the processes
that lead to those properties of
productivity and sustainability
stability and equitability over time so
long story short we combine those six
variables and actually there were quite
a few indicators that led to those six
variables using analytical hierarchy
process combine that into an index of
agro-ecosystem health that the men and
get an idea of how you were doing and
compare one place to another and even
more importantly where a Grieco system
health was a bit lower you can drill
down and figure out why so what are the
underlying variables that you could work
on to improve the health of that part of
the agro-ecosystem the most quickly and
that's a little bit background on how we
think about agro ecosystems and
agro-ecosystem health it's this
combination of social and biophysical
dimension find that lead to this pattern
on the landscape healthy agro ecosystems
are becoming very important there are
some predictions that suggest that
agriculture is going to get harder to do
over time so these are the climate
change predictions for our part of the
world that's the Upper Midwest I live
right about there in Worcester Ohio and
in this map on the Left darker blue
means more predicted heavy rainfall
events so we're in a part where we're
expecting more heavy rainfall events
this one on the right is prediction for
increase in consecutive dry days and
once again we're there where it's a
little bit darker so we're expecting
more heavy rainfall events and more
consecutive dry
is wetter when it's wet drier when it's
dry and no predictability so far about
what the pattern is are we talking about
three years of drought and then three
years of rain or one month the drought
one month or rain and until you can
figure that out you really don't have a
good way of adapting to that or knowing
what you have to do to adapt to that new
pattern so for me the element that best
describes these predictions of climate
change is in this row in the periodic
table of elements that you usually don't
spend a much time on in chemistry class
and there's a gap in the middle of them
they all start with you you uh the
element of surprise and I think that
describes pretty well what we're up
against with climate change just a lot
of surprises and a lot of them not
necessarily real pleasant surprises so
how you adapt agriculture I'm not sure
how many of you have seen this diagram
this is from the resilience Alliance and
it's kind of an early version of the the
figures that they use to describe how
systems change over time and you
probably recognize this contribu from R
to K which is kind of the classic
disturb to more conserve kind of climax
vegetation so the eco systems and social
systems tend to go back and forth
between these two poles in sustainable
agriculture a lot of what we do is when
we plow a field we're pushing it back
towards this exploitation area because
we want to exploit it for food and of
course we create an environment that
pests and diseases and the light can
exploit very well so a lot of
sustainable agriculture is trying to
strike that balance and getting the
system to act more like these conserve
systems where we get we need out of it
but it's not so exploitable by other
organisms so that you have these wild
outbreaks of diseases and that's alright
but what happens occasionally is the
environment changes to the point where
everything that was conserved and
working real well here just doesn't work
anymore
and it all gets released and then in
that release is that working out there
there it is
yeah so in that release there's a chance
for all of that that have been conserved
up here to get reorganized and then go
back into this cycle again and in that
reorganization you can actually lose
some capacity so they desert of vacation
or something like that loss of a seed
bank so you no longer have some of that
capacity to reorganize so when we talk
about resilience we're talking about
what happens when there's a big change
in the environment well these
predictions of climate change would be a
big change in the environment in which
we're currently producing food so that
that list of challenges is one that Fred
Kirschenmann throws at us all the time
he's part of this network of catalog
chairs and other scholars you want to
talk sustainable agriculture tell me how
you're going to farm with higher
temperatures more extreme weather half
the water and oil at $300 a barrel and
that would be very difficult to do
agriculture the way we do it now under
those conditions so that's an
environmental change that will cause a
big shift part of the definition of
resilience is about how much change the
system can go through and still bounce
back to where it was so there's this
kind of stability part of the definition
can they take a shock and go back what's
more important is when the environment
really changes how can the system adapt
and get through that what what they call
in the resilience alliance the back loop
of release and reorganization and adapt
and regain the functions that were
really concerned about like everybody
having enough to eat so the kind of
qualities of a system that make it
better able to go through that back loop
of release and reorganization or
self-organization the capacity to learn
and adapt which typically requires some
diversity that you can then select from
in that adaptation
and what kind of qualities would we look
for in agro ecosystems then well there's
diversity in terms of what we produce
and if you go to markets in other part
of the world you'll tend to find a whole
lot more things that people are eating
than what you'd find at Wegmans there
were probably a whole lot of things that
people were eating in this area that
we're not consuming anymore that people
were eating before European settlers
arrived so there's a whole lot of things
out there that we don't necessarily
consume that we could we could be
thinking about that you can be thinking
about the diversity within the things
that we do eat so there's the phenotypic
genotypic and gene by environment
interaction kind of diversity that you
have within crops of given crop and then
there's diversity in terms of who's
doing agriculture right now it's down to
about 1% of our population that are on
big farms but a lot of people getting
interested in getting reengaged with
agriculture so that would give you some
diversity once again and if you think
about it those qualities especially with
self-organization and innovation as some
of the things that link these dimensions
of agro-ecosystem health it's very
consistent this idea of agro-ecosystem
health leading to resilience so there's
some ideas about that published in a
paper in Jess if you're interested in in
those kind of questions so this is kind
of given us a lot of guidance on the
kind of work that we're doing in the
agro ecosystems management program this
is an example of a small and mid-sized
farms grant that we have is a small farm
just to the west of Worcester that was
donated to a RDC we have a grant to look
at the very early stages of diversifying
a farm that's been in corn and soybeans
not big enough to really make a living
doing corn and soybeans so if you're not
going to do that and do economy of scale
then what are you going to do
and economists are calling this economy
of scope the idea that you diversify and
then use the diversification as a way of
recapturing some of those input costs
that you would otherwise be spending if
you were going the other route into
economies of scale so we've got oil seed
crops forage vegetables pasture poultry
all kinds of things going on there and
what we're looking at in this project is
how quickly are the new benefits in
terms of soil quality access to markets
and things like that as well as new
costs cropping up this is a project that
we've had for some time if the idea of
this social networking site is
connecting entrepreneurs along supply
chains so that they're launching entire
supply chains instead of just one
business in the middle of a non-existent
local or regional supply chain which is
kind of tough to hang on while you're
doing battle with Walmart waiting for
everybody else to show up so the idea is
well let's get the planning going more
in cahoots and launch the entire chain
and it has features on there for
entrepreneurs to connect with each other
along supply chains collaborate on their
business plans there's a sneak peek at
the next version of it so we're just
about to launch this and this has
sections for both the bloggers who want
to share deep thoughts about food which
is great they could be investors at some
point but then you have the
entrepreneurs and they're the ones that
are really what the site is about is
helping them develop plans that lead to
entire supply chains as well as a
section that's for economic developers
so it becomes their tool that they can
use to support that entrepreneurship
which really is their job but
agriculture is a tough place for
economic developers to work as you're
talking about lots and lots of
businesses and they're spread out all
over the place so here's one example of
one of the supply chains that was
evolving as part of this project this is
a very large dairy farm up in Ashtabula
Ohio that little silvery thing down at
the bottom is not the swimming pool
that's called the lagoon it's not
something you want to get into
so this dairy farmer needed a way of
dealing with the stuff in the lagoon and
his choice he got involved with talking
about a bio digester with a company
called quasar and this is a bio digester
they have on our campus at O ard C and
that would give them a place to put the
cow manure that would generate heat and
methane so he's got a lot of cows he's
already got heat and methane he doesn't
care about those products he just wants
to get rid of the manure because he
needs that to get his sighting permit
but there was a small vegetable grower
down the road who wanted to say to green
house next to the bio digester used the
heat and methane to grow vegetables all
winter he already had a contract with
the local school system and they were
willing to collect their food waste and
send it back to the bio digester and you
need to combine food waste and manure
actually to make the bio digester work
really well so that's a good example
kind of classic industrial ecology where
that output from one business becomes
the input for the next business and it
all cycles very efficiently on a
landscape and those are the kinds of
flows that we had envisioned many years
ago as being the kind of flows that
would lead to healthy agro-ecosystem
full disclosure this never actually
happened the the negotiations broke down
between the dairy farmer and the bio
digester builder so it they never could
quite get it together to put all this in
place but it's a great idea it's waiting
out there so if any of you have a bio
digester and know any vegetable growers
it's still waiting to happen
so to really understand what we've got
on the Ohio landscape you have to go
back in time like well before we develop
the agro-ecosystem hip health index
about 1.8 million years that takes you
to the end of the Pleistocene which is
the last time Ohio was extensively
glaciated so that dark area at the top
is the glaciated area of Ohio that River
the tazed River was where that mouse
just doesn't want to do it this here was
what paleo geologists say was the
drainage before that ice age came up
from the southern Appalachians arced
through Ohio and then down the
Mississippi
but the glaciers did is kind of
bulldozed all of this rich gray shal
glacial till into those deep river
valleys and created really productive
fertile soils and also rearranged the
drainage so it's now what you'd
recognize the Ohio River going down to
the Mississippi I have to sheepishly
admit I don't remember this from the
geology course that I took here but I
didn't think that was at the same time
that the Finger Lakes
and kind of glacial geology so show me
you've taken the course more recently
heaven okay but I so we took a walk in
robert riemann yesterday and I do
remember taking the walk and Robert
Riemann with the professor in that
course and you hearing all about this in
terms of gorges and I think you're like
so anyway this is what was happening
just to the west and what had led to is
a real opportunity for people in this
state so that's the Glacial divide just
keep your eye on the line between the
glaciated and unglaciated and that is
median household income in 2000 in 2000
yeah we do that one more time so keep
your eye on the line again so if there's
any question that our wealth is coming
from our soils that helps me get to ask
that question these are very fertile
productive soils also leads to a state
with a lot of diversity so that's a
Gordon vegetation index map but I don't
expect you to read the legend but the
point is there's a lot of different
kinds of plant communities in Ohio we
straddle for EPA ecological zones so
there's a tremendous amount of diversity
so fast forward a few million years to
about 1800 and this is what European
settlers are finding so Columbus is
right there the Ohio rivers down here
this was kind of prairie and this was
all woods the early settlers figured the
Prairie was kind of useless because you
couldn't even grow trees there but what
they figured out very quickly is these
river valleys we're really good for
growing corn so this is the Scioto River
this little finger coming down
here to the Ohio and they figured out
real quickly you could grow a lot of
corn in those river bellies so it's 1804
1810 you got a lot of corn what are you
gonna do with it there's nobody around
it's the Ohio frontier there's maybe two
military Gareth Garrison's along the
Ohio River where you could sell it what
are you gonna do with corn anybody got
an idea give it legs yeah feed it to
cows so a guy named William Renwick in
1813 figured out that you could make a
tidy profit by producing corn-fed beef
and sending it over the mountains and
selling the beef on the international
market out of Baltimore and we had a
1,500 head CAFO confined animal feeding
operation in Coshocton in 1850 in ohio
so what else can you do with corn I
think yes for a minute so there were
stills all over the Ohio frontier not
because it was perpetual Spring Break it
was because that's something you could
do with corn dad value so you could turn
it into whiskey you put the whiskey on
flatboats and float those down the Ohio
River to New Orleans and sell it on the
international market and then you could
also take the brewing grains and feed
that to animals pigs and alike so there
were two distilleries and about nine
breweries in Cincinnati producing
turning the corn into ethanol and then
taking all those bird grains and feeding
them to pigs which you could also chop
up and put in barrels with a lot of salt
and sell that on the international
market out of New Orleans
I love these quotes about what life was
like in Cincinnati back in those days it
was called porkopolis and that bottom
quote is perfect Cincinnati originated
perfected the system that packs 15
bushels of corn into a pig and packs the
pig into a barrel and sends them over
the mountain isn't over the ocean to
feed mankind all right so that's 18 20
and we fast forward to about now well
first that's a statue of a flying pig
there are those statues all over
Cincinnati this is
College of Biological Sciences we can't
let that go without addressing it so
this is the Lord Brabazon of Tara the
First Lord Brabazon of Tara who
demonstrated in 1909 by strapping a
basket on to the wing of his biplane and
then putting a pig in the basket and
then taking off into the sky the pigs do
indeed fly this is back when the ruling
class not only approved of science they
actually got involved in it testing
hypotheses like this the BI tenders
bystanders tended to say that the pig
didn't seem to have a lot of choice but
the pig did fly so this is what you see
these days if you look at Ohio from
space so remember the Gordon vegetation
index map we can grow all kinds of stuff
we grow all of the things on this long
legend somewhere but you see five things
and you can see that line of where the
glaciers were again and all that stuff
on the lower right is grass and trees
and on the upper left it's corn and
we've added soybeans so that's what we
accomplished in about 200 years we've
added soybeans we're still growing a lot
of corn we still feed it to animals in
Capo's and we produced meat and we sell
that on the international market and we
produce ethanol for transportation fuel
there is one other thing that's changing
in this picture though all those gray
spots that's where people live so we're
not what we're not in the situation the
settlers we're faced with in the early
1800s there actually are some people
around that you could sell stuff to and
people are starting to figure that out
but if you go out why why does it look
like this then you know if you have all
these local markets right there and
you're still producing corn and soy
beans everywhere what's the deal here
and if you talk in the farm community
there's a lot of focus on we feed the
world this is what we have to do because
we feed the world and I have a lot of
respect and admiration for people that
are driven by that goal we want to feed
somebody we want to feed the world and
that's a great thing but the data isn't
necessarily lining up with that
statement so if you look worldwide it's
approximately one in nine people
chronically malnourished
with all the disease and a lack of human
potential or decrease in potential that
comes along with that it's not because
farmers aren't producing enough so if
you look at these are FAO statistics by
the way you look at per capita food
availability about twenty seven ninety
kilocalories per person per day so I
think its calories actually so what how
many calories does it take to sustain a
person for a day
2,500
two thousand
and who yeah how so if you're Michael
Phelps it's a lot more don't try to do
what he does but its bottom line is
that's more than what it takes to really
maintain each person in terms of caloric
requirements so it's not because there
isn't enough it's because obviously it's
not getting to people who need it and
another interesting statistic is that
people think that this all comes from
these really large farms because they're
really efficient they have really high
yields it turns out 70% of the supply is
still coming from small farms and even
though large farms have a lot of the
land area it's not the majority of the
food that's being produced so these are
kind of global figures the one a9 we own
it in Ohio so this is the most recent
census it just came out several weeks
ago we've now been joined by Maine and
Oregon as northern states with higher
than the national average food and
household food insecurity rates but the
census before that we were the only one
out of the south that had higher the
national average food insecurity rates
in Ohio so it's about 16% of households
that's one in six of our neighbors
experiencing low food security six point
six percent very low we'll get to that
in a minute but it goes way up for
households with children
single mothers people of color the same
kind of categories that are affected by
kind of class issues and poverty so this
is not the picture of a system that's
sustainable or resilient this is what's
be that where those low and very low
food security figures come from so the
darker the middle shade of blue is low
food security its those top three
categories so worried kind of this all
the stress of not knowing where your
next meal is coming from plus a change
in the diet so don't feel like you can't
afford a balanced meal very low food
security you started getting into
actually going hungry but even for low
food security that's one in six of our
neighbors there's an impact on what
people are eating and it's not just
hunger and lack of food that's a food
system issue so that obesity type 2
diabetes diet related disease is a huge
food security issue we know that a lot
of what's marketed for children is not
great nutritionally so that there's
actually more people that are
experienced obesity than chronic hunger
and malnutrition these days and that is
a food system issue the the current
statistics are that a lot of volunteers
for the military are being rejected
because they're obese so once again
we're back to having trouble raising an
army so the US government is starting to
pay attention to this pretty seriously
and then you have these predictions of
serious food shortages across the planet
by 2050 so it's questionable whether
we've even solved that one problem but
we've certainly that that one problem of
he who has no food has only one problem
you as food has many problems we have
enough calories we still got some issues
so these are some of the issues that the
Ohio State discovery themes are meant to
have an impact on so the three discovery
themes are energy and environment health
and wellness food production and
security if you look at sometimes
they're called Grand Challenges
challenge themes they come by different
names in different universities these
are not unique to Ohio State you'll find
those themes elsewhere but these are the
three that are trustees back in about
2010 several years ago figured were
themes that Ohio State would have
strengths to resolve so they were
willing to put some resources into those
strengths and a new tipped you off on
the amount that's being invested there
is this new source of revenue at Ohio
State miss because someone in the
business office figured out that we're
university so why are we screwing around
with managing parking lots and there are
a lot of parking places on the Cologne
campus about 35,000 of them so running
the parking lots is kind of a big effort
I figured well let's lease that to
somebody else let them do the parking
lots won't focus on research and
education so they leased it to a company
from Australia for four hundred and
eighty five million dollars over the
next 50 years which is a big slug of new
resources and someone else in the
Provost office said you know you should
tie that to faculty salaries so there
was a decision because faculty are
revenue generators so that's the route
that we go and then we had a Provost who
is also very willing to make this very
bottom up so from the very beginning
it's been you know faculty you tell us
how you want this to work started with
faculty advisory boards and laying out
what are the sub themes within those big
three that we might actually be able to
address the Ohio State and then we did
the cluster analysis and they kind of
clustered into data analytics food for
health materials and energy and then
infectious diseases so there were calls
for proposals in each of those and I'd
let a group around climate in the
environment on developing a framework
for data analytics and then the next
round of proposals came out on these
other three themes and together with
about 50 faculty across the university
we came up with a proposal for food
security just going into some of the
questions on who was asking this was a
result of about 20 years of reaching out
across the university through the agro
ecosystems management program and
developing relationships with people in
other colleges so when we put out the
call for the email is they may want to
get together and talk about this
we had people showing up from many
different colleges that we already were
working with so people in the Department
of art the Knowlton School of
Architecture Glenn School of Public
Affairs public our College of Social
Work so it was a very diverse group that
showed up on the table and developed
this proposal that became in fact
and this is the vision and approach that
we become a worldwide leader in
conceptual models but also practical
examples of a transform food and
agriculture that leads to secure
equitable food security for all that we
start with the food system that we own
at Ohio State University because we own
about a depending on who you talk to and
which day somewhere between thirty and
thirty nine million dollar annual food
bill between student dining the medical
school all the ways that we procure food
at Ohio State it's going to take
collaboration across the sciences
engineering and humanities as well as
outside of the university with many
partners outside it takes a holistic and
transformative approach this is not
tinkering and solving one problem after
the next the whack-a-mole game this
really is taking a transformative
approach and it does start with the
thirty new hires now another interesting
little sidelight is when we were given
the go-ahead to proceed with in fact it
was a go ahead on these thirty hires so
we had proposed that we're gonna start
with our own food system and we're gonna
change our campus landscape
nobody was putting us in charge like
campus dining or the campus landscapes
and the like so since then just last
year there was a set of sustainability
goals set by the university one of which
was increase the production and purchase
of locally and sustainably sourced food
to forty percent by 2025 and the provost
and vice president for student life
commissioned a panel that's now being
chaired by myself our executive director
the head of Dining Services and a
student to figure out the action plan so
we actually do have our hands on the
Ohio State food system now and can make
that part of this initiative
as well as the kind of research and
teaching and outreach that these new
faculty colleagues will be pursuing so
five main areas where we're doing this
hiring of the thirty hires one is in
climate-resilient food production and
it's it's actually not just production
it's also the processing the
preservation the distribution logistics
so it's that entire food system from the
the soil to the plate and it's not just
about changing a particular system it's
thinking about diversifying that entire
approach so here's a good example this
is Coachella ba Bo the guy in the center
there and he's one of several people
I've met who just decided you know this
food system doesn't work for our
neighborhood so they heck with it I just
do in my own and so he started clearing
off vacant lots getting the Somali youth
in the neighborhood to help with it
producing collards African basil selling
and preparing it and selling it in the
new harvest cafe which is behind that
mural and these are some of my students
trying to keep up with them it's a very
energetic guy and so it's it's about you
know how do we diversify any given
system and across systems of production
and and and the rest of the food chain
there's a medic medical and nutritional
and health dimension to this so the
medical community is embracing this idea
that food is health I don't know where
they heard that but there's this is a
garden that's being developed by one of
my colleagues in the medical school the
school of health and rehabilitation
science for cancer survivors and what
she's doing is checking the biometric
stats on the cancer survivors that are
out there working in the garden putting
numbers behind this idea that this
actually is really good for you to get
involved in this kind of thing and ship
your diet and to be working outdoors
producing food and sharing it so there's
the nutrition and health
there's the policy dimension because
policy does shape our school system or
our
food system works so this is a site
maintained at the Glenn College of
Public Affairs a colleague Jill Clark
who's done a great job of holding local
food policy councils together in Ohio
since we had a state food policy council
haven't had it since the last
administration came into into power but
we've been pulling together this group
of many local councils into a statewide
coalition there's an entrepreneurship
and business opportunity to all this if
you're going to develop new local and
regional supply chain there's an
opportunity for new businesses and this
was a study done by the bush consulting
group for the fund for our economic
future in Northeast Ohio where they
identified that both in terms of jobs on
the left and revenues on the right what
you could get out of the agricultural
Biosciences so it's agriculture RIT very
broadly it is much greater than some of
these other areas like Advanced Energy
industrial water flexible electronics
that people were kind of gaga over
because they're high tech and that top
part of the bar after the big thick bar
here that is import substitution so it's
basically producing in Ohio what
otherwise we would be imported
it's an enormous economic opportunity so
entrepreneurship and business are part
of it and then finally culture and
that's why it's a capital C in
agriculture because this food is very
basic to our culture I've done this
exercise of asking students you know
reflect on your experience with food and
invariably it very quickly gravitates to
special occasions with family often
religious holidays so that is culture
there's a cultural dimension to this the
top left picture is worldwide there are
many different approaches to food in
different cultures the bottom picture is
actually Columbus Columbus public health
market so we have a very diverse
community in Columbus Ohio as well as in
a lot of the United States and at the
end of the day it's one of these kids
experiencing
and how are they going to grow up
thinking about food and food systems so
those are the five broad areas these are
the the position descriptions or the
position titles wherever there's a
Buckeye there's somebody already hired
six of those are already on campus so
everybody but this one sheet she arrives
Ingrid Adams arrives from Kentucky on
December 1st all of the green circles
are searches that are underway the
yellow ones are search or positions that
are kind of Chum during through the
approval process and the white ones are
the ones that we've still got a little
bit of work to do and the deal here is
the office of academic affairs is
providing half of a salary for each of
these positions the other half has to
come from the department of college that
that person is gonna be in a lot of new
partnerships being built here so this
food health and human behaviors College
of Medicine but the person's actually
tenured in extension it's never happened
before this agro ecosystems management
is going to be shared between the
Department of horticulture and crop
sciences and animal sciences we've never
had a position shared between those two
units before so we are pushing the
culture within the university and to me
that's one of the most important things
here we got together as a group of
faculty across 10 different colleges and
came up with these ideas and now we're
going to departments that's completely
different from the way it has worked for
my entire career at Ohio State it's
always been strictly within a department
and I checked with our administrators we
think this is right that's the last time
we got together and talked about who we
were gonna hire and why as a faculty
across the universe actually these are
not faculty those are students this is
actually the first graduating class at
Ohio State and that's a very famous
stereoscope photo so it's the deal where
you put the thing in there and to look
at it one on each eye that comes to 3d
so anyway but it was a long time ago
that was about 1870 and this is just the
first step the hiring the people in the
next step is weaving the network so
we've actually envisioned
the network that we would expect between
departments interdisciplinary programs
external partners for all 30 of these
people so that inner ring is the 30 new
hires and all those lines if you can
possibly follow them is the network that
we would expect initially and it'll be
interesting to see how the network
actually developed but that's the next
real chore for me that's faculty
director so that's the handbook that's
on my desk these days the network weaver
June Hawley is right down in Athens and
this a real innovator in network weaving
I'll just give you a real quick sample
of one of the projects that's emerging
because I'm involved in this one but we
have a linkage and leverage Grants
Program so linkages how many people can
unique connect leverages how well can
you use it as a seed for new resources
coming in and those are on our website
which you'll see them in yeah so here's
the food mapping team we did a study in
the Gulf Coast counties of Mississippi
where we looked at what's the cost of a
representative low cost balanced diet
the USDA thrifty food plan as a function
of where you live so it's the cost of
all the items in the USDA plan as well
as the cost of getting around to round
it all up and that changes as a function
of where you live that's the map it's
about a two-fold difference if you don't
have a car it's about a four fold
difference and we did this because I've
never really liked this idea of food
deserts that there's a line here and
it's a food desert there and it's not
over here you have these places where
it's a very gradual transition in the
increasing cost and the point is that we
say very blithely food is cheap in
America well it depends on where you
live and who you are and the real
interesting part that we're gonna repeat
the study in Columbus to get at this is
what's the median income for people in
those areas that are in red and how big
a percentage of their income is it the
other project that we're working on in
addition to doing that food scape in
Columbus is new faculty hire in the data
analytics initiative who's doing an
agent-based model of people how people
actually respond to that Lance
and of course they cut corners it
affects the diet and we have colleagues
in the medical school who can get from
diet to what are the health outcomes so
if you're talking about the answer is a
new grocery store somewhere or a new bus
line somewhere you have a way of
predicting who is that gonna help and
how much and what's the health outcome
could it be so that's a flavor of the
kind of research that we're pulling
people together to do that's the website
we've hired Bryan Snyder as our
executive director he's just starting
and I better stop there and take some
questions if there are any but I'm
around tomorrow as well so I'd be glad
to get together with you and pursue this
further thanks again
would encourage the establishment arts
especially under resource your program
any relationship with that growing
we already do bring to green or the
middle have a food bank and children's
hunger Alliance Columbus public health
there are quite a few partners and
they're really the ones that can help
one of the things that were we have a
pending proposal that would allow us to
take this new purchasing that Ohio State
is willing to do and directed at the
community and people who get people help
in getting instant reduction if that
would help their situation I'm not
worried about whether it's full-time or
part-time I think hard times actually it
was mine but to do that those folks are
going to need a lot of support of the
training
things like that we have a tremendous
number of community partners have any
hope for that sort of thing so yeah
absolutely and then you know we talk
about agricultural transformation
transformation we can help it urgent
from the university research and
education the transformation that
happens outside with the exception of
the food system that's why
question we have questions up in Geneva
sorry we have a tradition to do it this
way listener you recognize those case
done necessarily is amazing
was there a question
yeah
State 22 deer down the line
okay that was my to graduate school in
February and we're right back to this
Antonio asked what's my vision for the
food system programs at Ohio State 20 30
years down the line I'd like to see this
initiative grow I think there's an
expectation that it becomes part of the
formal structure at Ohio State
University what's more important to me
is that it becomes part of the culture
at Ohio State that we continue this
tradition of getting together across the
colleges to talk about Louie hire why
and how we can progress on some of these
really big challenges and also how we
partner with the people outside the
university who are really the agents of
change out there so that would be my
vision is that this leads to a
transformation in the way we operate and
a transformation having food and
agriculture
whether they're hurdles both
domestically and internationally yeah I
would I would say in the hurdles are
many and they would be in each of those
five dimensions I mentioned so there are
hurdles that have to do with how do you
gain new economies in production not
just economy of scale but kind of your
scope how do you things like we have a
strong group in precision agriculture so
how do you take that technology and make
it scale independent so that's helping
farmers across any different scale you
know one example of the kind of research
that would be needed to to get to that
vision so there's I think hurdles
they're hurdles in the health fields
policy the business and entrepreneurship
and you know how the private sector
engages with this and then finally
culture you know how is it that we have
16% the low household and food security
in Ohio and nobody knows about it and
nobody is out screaming and
demonstrating in the street so there's a
cultural dimension and a cultural hurdle
to overcome on this both here in
innovation
however changing the radiance
yeah great question because I've been
working folks in landscape architecture
for two years before we're and well I
haven't city and regional planning which
is also in school of architecture and
those folks are you know very interested
in this question that's how do you plan
or Landscape Architecture designers tend
to look at these things in a very
holistic way but a completely different
way that I work so I already gained
something from talking to landscape
architecture there live landscape
architects and how they're designing but
they design a very similar principle to
what we're designing agricultural
production practices and things like
that where they're they're building in
ecological and economic and social
dimensions of the design and you need to
understand that I was in a design
charrette
last week in landscape architecture on
adaptive agro ecology and this is one of
our supporters Lipchitz she came from
Helles to you she's featured this month
on the cover of landscape architecture
magazine but where she was doing in the
catfish run and she works at these very
broad agro-ecosystem scales and and is
interested in visualizing what who knew
who had laid those systems might look
like and you know what do they look like
now how are you where are the
opportunities to search anything so this
design charrette I asked in the middle
of it had a common key it's you're
really doing a good job you know
bringing those principles and most of
them actually have not had a course in
the ecology and it becomes the reading
that they have to catch up
so I think you know that's that's an
example where we have something to
contribute to what they're doing in
landscape architecture they're very
quick to reach out to us to help
especially with that part of it but then
they also come up with these ideas this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu